[Applause]
come on
thank you in what's being called heroics
of New York's finest body camera video
shows NYPD officers rescue a man who
fell on a Manhattan train track just
seconds before the train arrived
thank you
it happened on November 24th at the East
116th and Lexington Avenue Station at
the time NYPD officers Brunel Victor and
to puke booze were conducting a Transit
sweep when they were told a man fell
onto the tracks body camera video shows
officers rushing for the tracks where
the man had fallen they arrived to find
another person had already jumped onto
the tracks in an effort to help the man
back onto the platform with the help of
that Good Samaritan officers lit the man
off the tracks
body camera video then shows one of the
officers attempt to hoist himself up
onto the platform but fall back that's
when the Good Samaritan grabs his hand
seconds after everyone was removed from
the tracks the train arrives at the
station
officials say the man who fell in the
tracks may have had a medical issue
after he was rescued another responding
officer provided Medical Aid until
additional First Responders arrived the
man was then taken to the hospital with
minor injuries
the police commissioner kishan Sewell
tweeted a video of the rescue saying the
officers courage is quote second nature
for the latest developments in this
story and all things True Crime stay
with long crime Network I'm Sierra
Gillespie